[Music]
on this tuesday night if you're sick and
tired of the pandemic
you're not alone this sucks
it really really does covid19 fatigue
how plenty of canadians are feeling it
and the advice
to get through it new restrictions
across europe and italy rioters
are fired up while in spain politicians
are under fire
for apparent hypocrisy canadians who
cross the border
every day there was some you know
discrimination i would say
one pandemic two countries and two very
different responses
and ballots from beyond the u.s the
campaign to get americans abroad
to vote
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is clear there is covid fatigue in
this country
and it's no wonder we've been living
with restrictions on where we can go
and who we can see for almost nine
months and yet as winter approaches
case numbers are climbing again and the
number of people dying of covid19 in
canada
is slowly creeping up too today prime
minister justin trudeau summed up the
challenge
in simple terms we're in an
unprecedented global pandemic
that really sucks this is really
difficult
it's a time where we need to do the
right thing we need to lean on each
other we need to use all the tools we
can
more on covet fatigue in a moment first
take a look at these numbers in ontario
more than 800 people got positive test
results today
in quebec more than 900 new cases were
reported manitoba set another daily
record 183
in saskatchewan almost 60 new cases were
reported
alberta had more than 420 today and in
bc
217. lots of people who get coveted 19
don't get very sick but some people do
get extremely ill and others
die and today canada hit a grim new
milestone
the number of canadians who have died of
covid 19
has now surpassed 10 000. in the past 24
hours in quebec 19 people died and
though the number of deaths each day in
canada
is much lower than it was in the spring
it's beginning to creep up
public health experts say it could
escalate quickly if the virus spreads to
more elderly and more vulnerable people
preventing that from happening requires
canadians to follow the public health
rules and restrictions
it worked in the first wave but as
michael couture reports covet
fatigue is a big factor in what happens
this winter
a foot above fitness is one of the few
gyms still open in ottawa
the owner claims that's because it's not
a gym rather he provides personal
services by appointment
like a hair salon he's racked up
nineteen hundred dollars in fines from
bylaw officers
but he says it's worth taking care of
his clients mental health mental health
mental health i can't say that enough
people just move around as your body
works for you then your brain works for
you
that mental health boost comes as
covid19 fatigue is permeating this phase
of the pandemic
a new ipsos poll for global news finds
that nearly half of canadians
say they're getting tired of following
public health recommendations and rules
regarding covid19 this sucks
it really really does putting it plainly
the prime minister admitted we could be
in
for a really tough winter justin trudeau
said his six-year-old son
even asked if covid19 will be around
forever
with case counts rising across the
country trudeau asked everyone to again
come together by staying apart i think
we have to ask ourselves who we really
are as canadians
are we really good neighbors
are we really people who care about the
most vulnerable about each other
i know we are and it doesn't mean we're
going to be perfect every step of the
way and it does mean we have to
continually remind ourselves to follow
public health advice
but i know canadians can get through
this together
canada's deputy chief public health
officer added it's about finding the
happy medium
between a full lockdown and a full
reopening which could allow covet 19 to
overwhelm the health care system
dr howard news says it all comes down to
social cohesion
support one another is in many different
ways it could be a you know looking out
for your your family members thinking
what you need to do to protect
your elderly parents or your loved ones
who may have underlying medical
conditions
those messages of encouragement also
came with a dose of reality
as prime minister trudeau warned
canadians have to be really careful now
if they still want to have large family
gatherings
at christmas donna okay mike lucatour in
ottawa thanks
in manitoba the situation is getting
worse by the day a record 183 new
infections were reported there today
144 of them in winnipeg 83 people are in
the hospital with kovid
15 are in intensive care and the
five-day test positivity rate
is at an all-time high 7.5 percent
manitoba's premier is deeply frustrated
and is pleading with people to stop
ignoring the rules people in parts of
europe are beginning to push back
against newly imposed covid19
restrictions there
the italian government has approved a
seven billion dollar relief package to
help sector's
hardest hit by the pandemic but there's
anger about a new round of tight
restrictions on what italians are
allowed to do
protesters some of them shouting freedom
smashed and looted shops and clashed
with riot police
and in spain one of europe's worst hot
spots strict new rules have been
reimposed under a second state of
emergency
redmond shannon on the reaction to
europe's powerful
second wave
glass in turin as italy breaks another
record for daily cases of coed 19
this the result of anti-lockdown
protests on monday
police say they fired tear gas after
dodging molotov
cocktails there were similar scenes in
milan and
marches against restrictions across the
country
bars and restaurants can now only serve
takeout after 6 pm
and many regions have nighttime curfews
this woman says allowing lunch service
but not dinner
makes no sense disquiet of a different
sort in madrid
bus drivers appealing for financial help
and medical staff demanding better
conditions to deal with the virus
spain also has a nationwide curfew and
new restrictions to deal with a sharp
second wave
if it's best because people are going
out yes it will slow it down
but i don't believe that any government
actually has a solution
150 spanish politicians and business
leaders are facing criticism
after attending this gala on monday
night we are all
outraged especially because this
party and these photographs come
basically one day after
that we have been asked by our
government
to stay home the minister of health was
among those in the crowd
a government spokesperson said all
protocols were adhered to
but some self-reflection is needed it is
for the entire population it is like a
slap in the face
spain's prime minister pedro sanchez
wants the current state of emergency to
last
up to six months redmond shannon global
news london
in the u.s the pandemic is playing
radically different roles in the
presidential campaign
a week to go and president donald trump
is playing down kovid 19 and holding
big rallies and states he hopes will
deliver him four more years in the white
house
his rival joe biden is observing public
health rules and holding smaller and
fewer events
where they go in this final week can
reveal where they see their strengths
and weaknesses jackson proskow explains
with one week to go joe biden found
himself campaigning in georgia
cautiously optimistic about a
breakthrough in a state democrats
haven't won since 1992.
i know this country i know our people
and i know we can unite and heal this
nation
donald trump returned to familiar
territory in michigan a state he's at
risk of losing
after winning by just 11 000 votes in
2016.
we're going to have a great red
wave this time around trump faces a more
complicated path
to victory the states that narrowly put
trump over the top in 2016 are leaning
toward joe biden
pennsylvania michigan and wisconsin the
president is also playing defense in
states he won
handily iowa ohio arizona
georgia north carolina and florida are
no longer
safe republican territory what this
means is that the democrats not only
feel like
we have the map on our side but there's
an opportunity to extend
the electoral victory in florida
former president barack obama made a
push to flip the state
attacking trump's leadership kovit
kovetkova he's complaining
he's jealous of kovitz media coverage
trump remains defiantly optimistic
insisting he's got a lock on a second
term we'll take back the house
we'll hold the senate we'll hold the
white house
in a year in which 67 million americans
have already voted
nothing seems certain with tight races
in swing states the unknown
impact of mail-in ballots and looming
court challenges over the vote
but those things i think only come to
play if this is this is sort of a repeat
of 2016 and
it's that it's a really close race um in
some
in some of these key states yet it's
hard to know if it will even be close
the states in play could deliver a rapid
decisive result on election night
one week out anything seems possible
jackson frost go global news washington
back in this country the federal
liberals hung on to two seats in toronto
and by elections yesterday but did
suffer a significant drop in support
former broadcaster marcie ian won the
riding of toronto center
the new green party leader annamee paul
came in a close second
businesswoman and activist yara sax held
on to york center but only got about 700
more votes than her conservative
challenger
the by-elections were the first
electoral test of the federal
government's handling
of the pandemic in saskatchewan the
saskatchewan party passed that test
voters delivered an historic win in the
provincial election there delivering a
fourth consecutive majority mandate
for the party led by scott mo it is the
first time that's happened in 60 years
global's caitlin wilson is following the
results for us tonight
caitlin donna less than one
hour after polls closed the call was
made the saskatchewan party winning its
fourth straight majority
now the longest serving government in
the country
tonight we're celebrating a big honkin
election win
a historic night for the province with
the sask party dominating in the rural
areas
campaigning on a platform of fiscal
responsibility
promising to balance the budget in the
next four years and build a strong
economy
saskatchewan is poised to do very very
well as the global
recovery starts at some point in the
future and we're going to do everything
that we can
to play saskatchewan in a position to
succeed the party also had strong
support in both saskatoon and regina
taking more seats than the ndp who hoped
to make advances
in the major cities instead it could now
find itself down a leader
ryan miley still waiting on his fate
this is not the end
this is the beginning but the surprise
of the night the success of the
right-leaning buffalo party
the party describes itself as a western
independence party
and finished second in four ridings and
third in the popular vote
signaling a frustration with the federal
government something scott moe
acknowledged in his victory speech we
are not happy with the federal
government either
and you have my word that we will
continue to stand up for saskatchewan
as we have always done but even with a
sask party win
the size of the majority won't be
confirmed until later in the week
after thousands of mail-in ballots are
counted donna
caitlin wilson in regina thanks there
are more job cuts coming to alberta's
oil sector after a multi-billion dollar
merger between sonova's energy and husky
energy
sonova says it aims to trim its
workforce by as much as 25 percent
after it acquires husky the move could
impact more than 2
000 jobs most of them in calgary it's
the latest blow to the alberta oil patch
suncor recently announced its intention
to reduce staff by up to
15 percent the man charged with shooting
and killing four people
in fredericton two years ago took the
stand in his own defense today
matthew raymond's lawyers argue he is
not criminally responsible due to a
mental disorder
today raymond told jurors that in the
lead-up to the shooting he believed
everything in the news major happenings
even traffic accidents were staged
he also testified that beginning in 2017
he thought some court cases were also
fake raymond claims he stopped believing
the conspiracy theories last year around
the time he was being treated
in a forensic hospital before his trial
he's facing
four counts of first-degree murder for
the deaths of two police officers
and two civilians out of control
infernos coming up what's fueling
california's raging wildfires
plus i'm jeff semple in a hospital just
outside detroit michigan with a tale
of two border cities i'll have that
story coming up
on global national fire crews are trying
to beat back two out of control
wildfires burning near los angeles an
evacuation order is in effect for nearly
100 thousand people
the powerful santa ana winds are fanning
the flames of both the silverado fire
and the blue ridge fire both broke out
yesterday
about five thousand firefighters are on
the front lines of fires across
california
in what is the worst fire season there
in 18 years
the canada u.s border has been closed to
non-essential travel for not
safely available the pandemic jeff
semple joins us from detroit tonight
jeff
what are you hearing
donna in the context of this pandemic
many canadians have come to think of the
u.s
border as our greatest protector from
the perceived covid
chaos in the united states but thousands
of canadians continue to commute across
this border
every single day some at great personal
risk
the ambassador bridge connecting detroit
with windsor is canada's busiest border
crossing but covet 19
closed the door to all but an essential
few
transport trucks and others like zane
ismail
ever since i've lived here and grown up
it's been like nothing to cross the
border and now there's all these
stipulations
ismail is one of around 1600 healthcare
workers
who live in windsor but work in detroit
the cities just a couple of kilometers
drive have recently seemed
worlds apart it's been really just
mentally challenging just to navigate
both worlds
the pandemic has been a tale of two
border cities
in windsor they've seen fewer than 3 000
confirmed cases of covet 19
while hospitals in detroit have seen
more than 180
000 nobody's really sure why detroit got
hit so hard it really was an epicenter
in some detroit hospitals 40 percent of
the staff
comes from canada anybody who
volunteered
in this i mean every one of them is a
hero it's just that simple
and as they crossed the border those
canadians received a hero's welcome
greeted and thanked by the u.s consular
general
but the reception when they returned
home to canada was
chillier there was some you know
discrimination i would say right at the
very very beginning
the mayor says there were reports of
cross-border workers being harassed
and refused entry into some shops there
was a
wide degree of fear by a lot of folks in
this community
this freelance journalist had been
reporting south of the border before
returning home to windsor last month
worried about her washington plates she
put this sign
in her window that said i am canadian
and i have completed the 14-day
quarantine
because i had read stories about people
with
american plates across canada having
their cars damaged or being harassed
just because they had u.s plates as
detroit's covet 19 caseload
dropped during the summer so too did
that concern about cross-border
transmission
but like in canada cases are now
climbing here again
in fact michigan just recently reported
a record
daily increase with more than 3 300
new cases donna okay jeff semple in
detroit thank you
still ahead a deadly blast at a school
in pakistan
protests turned violent in philadelphia
after another police shooting of a black
man and a warning
some of the video is disturbing
over a dozen people were arrested more
than 30 officers were injured last night
looters took advantage of the chaos
ransacking a number of businesses and
setting
vehicles on fire here's why they're
angry 27-year-old walter wallace was
shot and killed by the police during a
confrontation
that was captured on video yesterday
police claim
he refused to drop his knife
a bomb blast at a religious school in
northwestern pakistan has killed a
number of people and left more than 100
injured some of the video in this too is
hard to watch
that's the moment of the explosion
captured by amateur video investigators
say a bag packed with five kilograms of
explosives and ball bearings detonated
the cleric seen in that video appears to
have survived
but at least eight other people were
killed in the explosion
north poles next the big push to get
americans living in canada
to vote
one week until the u.s presidential
election and there's a parallel campaign
underway here in canada
there are about 660 000 americans living
in canada and democrats and republicans
are busy courting them
in the 2016 election only five percent
of them cast a ballot
there's a big push to up that number
this time robin gill
explains why there's no door-to-door
campaign to hand out
buttons instead volunteers like camille
mitchell
a democrat living in canada work online
channels
a lot of americans living here don't
know they can vote from here
they think they have to fly home to vote
they don't democrats are aggressively
recruiting expats
thanks to facebook ads and a spot on
spotify
if you or a parent were born in the
united states
you are one of them and you can vote
that campaign is aimed at americans
living in windsor ontario
just across the bridge from detroit
michigan a swing
state now their opponents republicans
overseas admit
they're not as well organized and get
the strategy
in 2016 trump won by only 11 000 votes
and i would bet my last dollar there's
more than 11 000 people with a right to
vote in u.s
elections in the windsor area alone so
does the expat vote
matter according to this political
scientist yes
the voting margins can be really slim
because it's not the total popular vote
hillary clinton won the
total popular vote al gore won the total
popular vote but they still lost the
election
because they lost the vote in key swing
states now here's where it gets
interesting because the democrats are
trying to encourage dual citizens to
vote
and that's where the republicans get
their backs up to the people who just
happen to have a technical claim to
american citizenship in canada
and who do not identify as americans i i
actually don't think should be voting an
american elections
but the democrats are undeterred they
say all americans need to show their
true
expatriate love imagine if every
american
overseas around the world voted the
impact that would have
it goes to show the philosophical and
political divide
even happens on this side of the border
robin gill global news
west vancouver and that is global
national for this tuesday i'm donna
friesen tonight's your canada is a bit
of a puzzle
oh my god i can feel this coming no the
rubik's cube that twisty little thing
that has confounded all kinds of people
has been bought by the canadian company
spin master
invented nearly 50 years ago by
hungarian erno rubik it is one of the
world's best-selling games and has over
3 billion
possible combinations i'm still trying
thanks for watching
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]
you